move aside Romani and harmony shippers
Hermione Granger is the brightest Witch
of her age and she could have dated
anyone in the Wizarding World we are
here to look at the people that Hermione
should have ended up with that aren't
her best friends grab your fan fictions
because this one's about to bring you a
lot of inspiration for your next story
JK Rowling had always intended for Ron
Weasley and Hermione Granger to end up
together but as she wrote the books they
became less and less compatible Hermione
values intelligence and social justice
run though smart in his own way just
isn't in the books and he definitely
isn't behind the rights of house elves
although he did redeem himself some when
he worried about the elves safety during
the Battle of Hogwarts Ron and Hermione
are always pushing each other's buttons
they fight all the time and Roly herself
has said that their relationship didn't
make much sense
they ended up together because she
wanted them to but she acknowledged that
the way the characters developed didn't
make them very compatible they were much
better off as friends plenty of people
expected Harry Potter to end up with
Hermione Granger Hermione and Harry were
always loyal whenever one or both of
them were fighting with Ron they still
had each other's backs but their
relationship was more like a
brother-sister bond Harry just like Ron
doesn't value learning just for the sake
of learning and both characters are very
strong-willed plus girls don't have to
date their guy friends so who should
Hermione have ended up with let's look
at a few options Viktor Krum Oh Viktor
Krum International Quidditch star and a
brooding Triwizard champion when
durmstrang was at Hogwarts for the
Triwizard Tournament girls and guys
alike were all over crumb after all he
had just caught the snitch in the
Quidditch World Cup even Ron totally
went crazy over crumb but Victor didn't
want fan girls instead Hermione Granger
caught his eye they started dating and
he took her as his date to the Yule Ball
Hermione shippers feel very strongly
about their OTP but did you know that
one of the directors was also a cremini
fan David Yates who directed Goblet of
Fire was so invested in Crom and
Hermione that he was going to make a
whole bunch of changes to Rowling story
there was going to be a serious love
triangle with
- in rhyme and crumb was going to come
out victorious Spees - would have been
great together Hermione was never
interested in them just because he was a
Quidditch star in fact she wasn't that
big of a Quidditch fan at all she liked
him for who he was inside that must be
hard to find when you're his famous is
crumb Victor was also willing to have a
long-distance relationship with her but
when they saw each other at villain
fleurs wedding it was clear he still
cared for her even if you're a cremini
shipper there are tons of great fix off
there check out cake check date double
check by Aurora zero seventy-seven on
archive of our own for some sweet fluff
pansy Parkinson this next pairing might
not be one that you have thought of
pansy Parkinson is the Slytherin
princess she's popular and good friends
with Draco Malfoy she is also one of the
sacred 28 the purest of the pure blood
families so why should she end up with
Hermione Granger well these two are
actually alike in more ways than one
first of all they are both good students
well we don't know much about pansies
Gray's
we do know she becomes a prefect pre
facts are considered model students of
their home and her teachers obviously
trusted her to have that responsibility
Hermione is also a prefect they both
beat out the rest of the girls in their
houses for the role they are both
extremely loyal to their friends pansies
family doesn't take sides during the war
but she continues to be besties with a
Draco even though he's a Death Eater and
she puts up with a lot just like Harry
Draco gets pretty angsty pansy and
Hermione are there to support their
friends even if they're worse
pansy also doesn't care quite as much
about blood status as her fellow
slytherins in the sixth book she and
blaze talk about how attractive Ginny
Weasley is but blaze wouldn't touch
Jenny because she's a blood traitor
let's not forget that Hermione said a
teacher on fire in the first year to
save Harry they are one fierce pair if
you're a pens 90 shipper you're not
alone look at this gorgeous fan art from
up the hill art on tumblr she makes a
ton of pens me art Oh
you saw Neville Longbottom in Sorcerer's
Stone Hermione and Neville Longbottom
have a lot in common they have no
friends they are made fun of a lot
whenever Snape bullied Neville Hermione
was there to help him
and while Neville may have been terrible
at potions he wasn't dumb in fact he was
the best student in their year at her
apology not only was he good at the
subject but he was passionate about it
Hermione is always passionate about the
subjects she likes Neville would also be
super into Hermione's causes he's just a
genuinely good guy she could count on
his support for the society for the
protection of elvish welfare he wouldn't
have made fun of her for it according to
cursed child
Hermione becomes the youngest Minister
for magic ever Neville would be so
supportive of her career and they both
value hard work and bravery Plus never
got way more awesome as the books went
on he killed Nagini with the sword of
Godric Gryffindor
Hermione would definitely appreciate how
hard he fought in the war he had a whole
resistance against the Death Eater
teachers in Deathly Hallows they would
be such a cute couple
and he would love her so much Ginny
Weasley
if Hermione has a thing for fiery
redheads Ron was not her only option in
fact we think Ginny Weasley would have
made a much better choice can you say
power couple Ginny and Hermione were
best friends these two shared a bedroom
every summer they would gossip together
Hermione could talk to Jenny about
emotional stuff that she couldn't talk
about with Ron and Harry
whenever jenny was upset Hermione was
the person she talked to Ginny is just
as fierce as Hermione she doesn't let
injustice slide she stands up for
herself when she gets bullied and she
can always put her brothers in their
place she is one of the leaders of the
student resistance of Hogwarts in the
last book and she is brave she doesn't
stay in the room of requirements when
the battle happens she fights Hermione
and Ginny even fights
Bellatrix Lestrange together Ginny is
also really smart and she was great at
spells like Hermione
no one casts a bad bogey hacks like
Ginny Weasley and later in life she
becomes a journalist she's one brilliant
witch can you imagine if these two
strong independent young women were
together they would be unstoppable they
also have enough differences that they
would never be bored Jenny loves
Quidditch
she never gives Hermione a hard time
about not liking it Jenny isn't into
politics but she would be super
supportive of Hermione they already know
each other so well it would be perfect
Janie and Hermione are well known
pairing in fanfiction read and we grow
into ourselves by me reverses on archive
of our own if you want to see this ship
in action Percy Weasley
there is fanfiction and fan out for just
about every Weasley sibling and Hermione
but there is one Weasley that hermione
has the most in common with and that is
Percy Weasley Percy is four years ahead
of Hermione at Hogwarts when we meet him
he is a Gryffindor prefect he and
Hermione have the same priorities they
are both really smart
in fact Percy is the smartest of all the
Weasley kids he puts his schoolwork
first he would definitely provide
Hermione the intellectual challenge that
she needs they would have the sweetest
nerdiest conversations and remember
hermione thought getting expelled was
worse than dying
they are also both really ambitious and
they care about politics they could
support each other in their careers and
together they could totally
revolutionize the Ministry of Magic okay
we know Percy totally turned his back on
his family for a while but he came back
when it mattered they would also both be
great parents because they would have
high expectations for their kids and
help them with school
Percy and Hermione are a total rare pair
in the Harry Potter universe and you can
find some really great fix the right
Weasley is buy eggs win on archive of
our own who do you think is actually the
right Weasley for hermione draco malfoy
germany shippers unite Draco Malfoy and
Hermione Granger are one of the most
popular pairings in fan fiction and
fantasy was really mean to Hermione
he called her a mudblood and made fun of
her all the time he did start to redeem
himself at the end of the books he lies
about knowing Harry Ron and Hermione at
Malfoy Manor is it because he had
feelings for Hermione Hermione was one
of the only people who would ever stand
up to Malfoy
remember when she punched him in the
face Malfoy needs someone to call him on
his bad attitude at the Yule Ball even
Draco was speechless when he saw how
beautiful her Miami was if Draco could
apologize
could be the perfect pair Draco is
really smart he's good at all his
classes and he even became a prefect
hermione values intelligence which he
has he would also be one doting
boyfriend he would be very loyal to
whoever he was with and he knows the ins
and outs of politics which would help
with her career Draco is anything but
lazy which Hermione would appreciate
they would provide each other with a
challenge which they both need Draco
could help Hermione realize that she
doesn't have to be right all the time
and Hermione would help Draco be a more
compassionate person there is no
shortage of amazing Germany's stories
out there and we love a good fan art
check out this drawing by little
Jumeirah on tumblr we are here for this
Germany shippers feel very strongly
about their OTP are you one of them what
happen are you ugly now I know you know
one we've talked a lot about what
character Hermione should have ended up
with and the internet will continue to
debate this for years to come
but let's look at another option what if
Hermione ends up with no one it's 2019
we know that strong women don't need a
partner marriage isn't for everyone
Hermione is fiercely independent and
cursed child we find out that she
doesn't even get rid of her maiden name
even her kids had the last name Granger
Weasley how modern Hermione always puts
school first but there's no reason to
believe that she wouldn't want to put
her career first fighting for house-elf
rights and becoming the youngest
Minister for magic ever we'll keep her
busy could Hermione balance a marriage
Anne's family
of course she could she could do
anything but what she want to Hermione's
idea of happily ever after may not
include romance and that's okay all we
are saying is that the girl has options
the important thing is is that Hermione
chooses the best option for herself
Hermione will be the brightest Witch of
her age whether she gets married or not
but Harry Potter fans have lots of
opinions on Hermione's love life maybe
you think Cannon is correct and Ron is
the best option or maybe you think one
of these other characters are a way
better match who do you think Hermione
should have ended up with and who is
your harry potter OTP let us know in the
comments thanks for watching it doesn't
matter whether you're a mug
or a wizard watch more magical videos
when you subscribe to the things
[Music]